how does
man respond to it differently than a
woman response to infidelity
great question so there's some fantastic
research that was done
uh back in the early 1990s where they
asked men and women
to imagine their partner either engaging
in sexual infidelity
or romantic infidelity romantic and
fidelity
your husband always has lunch with this
wonderful colleague of his they share
their dreams she understands his humor
so there's no sex it's all platonic but
there's an emotional bond that is
forming well guess what happens
men respond much more harshly to sexual
infidelity
women respond a lot more harshly to
emotional infidelity
why because again men are responding to
the threat of paternity uncertainty
women are responding to the threat of
you
removing your investment from the
relationship
and it turns out that it's a much bigger
predictor
of me packing my bags and leaving you if
i develop an emotional bond with
another woman rather than just a sexual
dalliance this is why men
oftentimes in a very uh
clumsy way when they are caught cheating
one time at a conference at
somewhere they'll say she meant nothing
to me it was a one-time thing
what they are effectively doing is
speaking to that evolutionary concern
which is
i could completely decouple my
investment in you
from the fact that i just had a desire
for sexual variety
now by the way when i explain these
things oftentimes people who hate
evolutionary think
theory will get upset because they think
that if you explain something
scientifically
this means that you are justifying it or
condoning it and i'm
of course doing no such thing right if
you're studying cancer
that doesn't mean that you are for
cancer it doesn't mean that you are
justifying and condoning cancer it means
that you're studying cancer
so if you want to understand all sorts
of ugly things that people do
you have to study them properly and
that's why i love evolution so much
so if you like this sort of shortcut
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye